out of all the students we know in my
here academia hitochi shinzo currently
has the odds most stacked against him
when it comes to becoming a hero not
only did his quirk make it virtually
impossible to pass the hero course exam
but his opportunity to shine at the
sports festival was diminished after
being paired against deku
who not only has the power of the
greatest hero ever
but also possesses some epic plot armor
according to shinzo himself
his desire to transfer onto the hero
course is shared by many students at ua
but it's clear from his declaration
against bakugou and basically the whole
of class 1a
that in his case he has the most
determination to succeed and actually do
it
today we're using all available
information to estimate
where shinzo will be in 10 years time
including whether he could end up being
a teacher at ua
however in order to do this i will be
going into spoilers from the manga
which means we will be discussing
certain things that won't appear on
screen
until season 5. but with that said you
know that is your spoiler warning
and let's get into it shinzo was 16
years old the last time we saw him in
the anime
and at the time it was noted how he
bulked up a little bit this was a subtle
hint towards the fact that he'd been
training with izawa since the sports
festival in much the same way that deku
and all might sneak off to have secret
training in the woods
i previously made a video explaining his
upgrades in depth
but to summarize them here hitoshi now
wears a support item called persona
chords
which allows him to copy the voices of
other people this then makes it easier
to trick people into responding to him
for example
he could copy izuku's voice and then
shout out something towards ochako
for a guaranteed reply on top of that he
now uses izawa's binding cloth as well
which is perfect for someone like him
whose quirk doesn't actually help him
physically
in the case of the professor it took him
five years to master this
so in shinzo's case could you imagine
how good he would be after a
year time skip as a 26 year old pro hero
he would be super experienced by this
point as when we look at the present day
many of the top 10 heroes are either 26
years old or younger
including mirko ryukyu and of course our
boy
hawks if we refer to vigilantes it was
also around this age that izawa decided
to begin his teaching career
at ua as well for shinzo there are a few
reasons why i don't see him becoming a
hero in like the top 10 or around that
area
the nature of his brainwash quirk means
it's probably best that he isn't a major
celebrity type hero
during the sports festival we saw that
at the start he was brainwashing people
left and right because no one knew what
his ability was
but then before the match against deku
ojoro told him how shinzo's quirk worked
which meant that he knew not to say
anything once he broke out of the spell
too bad he didn't take that advice from
the very beginning but what can you do
while shinzo's persona chords make it a
lot easier to still trick people
even if they know about his power in
reality i don't think it would be as
effective if he was a flashy hero
consistently in the newspaper headlines
and on the top of the billboard charts
like it just wouldn't work because
people would be way too aware of him
at this stage in his career at least i
see him more as being a friendly
neighborhood shinzo who
easily sneaks up on small time villains
and also backs up the major heroes
during stealth missions because of
everything i just mentioned i don't see
him being near the top 10
but that said i still think he'd rank
pretty good somewhere around 200th place
would be appropriate
similar to where manuel places in the
charts as well we've got to remember
there are
thousands of pro heroes in japan so
being ranked around this area would
actually be very good
in terms of whether he'd be a teacher at
ua during his spare time
i wholeheartedly think this would be the
case and there are a few reasons here
for those of you who've seen my next
generation video you'll know that by the
time we get to 10 years in the future
it would only be right that ua has
reformed the entrance exam
to accommodate heroes who don't have
combat focused quirks for example kids
with healing powers you know they're not
going to be destroying robots exactly
but yeah kids like that in the future
will get onto the course
and so for those students they'd likely
need additional classes to help build up
their basic strength
in the absence of izawa hitoshi would be
the perfect teacher for this
the professor wouldn't be available
because by this point in the storyline
if he's alive
i reckon izawa would be headmaster at ua
he was always someone who did things in
his own unorthodox way
so putting him in charge of the school
is what i think could lead to the
wholesale changes that i spoke about in
the first next generation video
especially regarding the entrance exam
as that was one of the things that
aizawa specifically said he did not like
the other reason i think he wouldn't
teach these classes is because
i mean he might be dead by this point as
i record this video the last chapter of
my academia
was 276 where we saw deku attacking
sugaraki
um so i'm really hoping you know by the
time i put this video out
that izawa has not died but even if he
survives this whole encounter in this
current war arc
we can't act like it's a certainty that
he'll live the next 10 years
so yeah it is possible that he might
have died either way whichever one
happens
shinzo is best placed to be the
inspirational teacher
to be giving these extra classes to kids
who need to build up their physical
strength
because he was i mean he's the
embodiment of that he's someone who came
into ua
with no strength whatsoever izara even
noted during the
sports festival that even though deku
wasn't at the level of a hero core
student
he was still way physically stronger
than shinzo by agreeing to teach these
kids alongside being a hero
he would have not only fulfilled his
goal of becoming a great hero
but also being one who helps raise the
next generation of heroes exactly like
him
because this is a time skip video i
think it's only right that i also talk
about
the most likely quirk evolutions after
all this time
currently shinzo has two big limitations
the first being that his enemies can
break out of his trance with a slap to
the head
or some other kind of physical force
this is a big deal
as if he's up against villains who are
working together then brainwashing one
of them is pretty useless if the others
can easily break them out
in my opinion the way it works right now
is a bit too flimsy
so to me in the future perhaps hitoshi
could brainwash people to the extent
where they genuinely can't escape unless
shinzo himself takes physical damage
this would be reminiscent of the way
that seji's quirk works in that he can
trap people inside his meat and they
can't escape they can't do anything to
break out
but if people on the outside were to
attack the user
then yeah in that situation they can
escape the second biggest weakness
currently of this quirk
is that he can't actually make people
draw on their own knowledge when giving
commands
he can give you basic instructions for
people to do things like walk out the
ring for example
but if you brainwash the villain and ask
them to type a code to disable a bomb or
something crazy like that
they wouldn't do it because that
requires them to think it would also be
super useful to use on villains in
tartus prison
as you can get vital information out of
them remember in the manga how they
tried so hard to get kirigiri to give up
any relevant information
well in the next gen you know if there's
a villain like that they could just call
shinzo in and he could literally just
brainwash the person and make them give
up whatever information they know
if you're interested in learning about
his upgrades more in depth then be sure
to check out this video i did last year
which explains all of that thank you
guys for watching as always
i'm currently away visiting family but i
recorded this video in advance so that i
could still put something out this week
so if you enjoyed it you know then i'd
appreciate if you could hit that
subscribe button
if you haven't already peace out